they're over a hundred miles from land
and their boat is just sunk they'd be
lost to the Mediterranean Sea if a multi
spotter plane hadn't passed overhead
these rare pictures show the very start
of yet another rescue effort to save
illegal immigrants they're Syrians
fleeing their civil war risking
everything to get to Europe the plane
dropped a life raft to help them over
the coming hours this became a joint
Maltese and Italian rescue effort
the survivors men women and children
picked from the water and taken to
patrol craft amongst them a little girl
and her father clutching each other her
twin sister has died as has her pregnant
mother as they change her soaking
clothes she knows none of this of course
many families were split here in Malta
some of the survivors waited a detention
center for news of their loved ones
they're hoping that they made it to
Italy it's heartbreaking he wants to
know whether they are dead or alive
but he would like to know he would like
to know an answer are they dead they're
dead
it's finished but if they're alive he
wants them to be reunited with Syrians
are just the latest of the nationalities
attempting to cross to Europe from Libya
the numbers are growing year on year
while the whole illegal immigrant issue
is a massive headache for Europe indeed
European nations will be discussing the
whole problem this week the authorities
are keen to point out that it only takes
place because of illegal trafficking
gangs they facilitate the movement of
people towards Europe in the case of the
Syrians they hadn't paid the proper
amount of money to the right gang in
Libya and they were attacked at sea by
gunmen and ultimately that is why their
boat capsized and that is why these
people died passing through the chaos of
Libya is almost as dangerous as a boat
trip itself
but they're prepared to do it staying in
Syria even worse for Syrians who might
still try to make this trip it is very
dangerous what do you what do you say to
them very dangerous but and will more
people try do you think while
traffickers have willing migrants
prepared to make this trip there will
inevitably be more tragic events in the
Mediterranean Sea and so far the
international community seems at a loss
as to know what to do about it
stuarti sky news Malta